i was very sensitive about people's
behavior
that's the essence of advertising to to
have your
senses all the time aroused and to to
listen to feel the things that people
don't say
to try to expect and to predict
their behavior welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
this episode is about advertising and
marketing meet robbie nissan
co-founder and chief business
development officer of fetcher ltd
robbie brings 22 years of experience in
the advertising and marketing
industry in israel former chief creative
officer in tbwa
and former founder and head of strategy
and creative at havas
robbie has vast experience in commercial
and political campaign management
and as a senior strategy consultant in
the wolfson foundation and other
international organizations
robbie nissan welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you today
i love the background that you have
behind you it's it's amazing
yeah and it's not a virtual background
actually
i'm like yeah my dream was my dream all
my life was to live in a record store
so once i had my own office i instead of
changing photos and pictures all day
long
you just change the covers you can
change the whole design
in one second i i love that what is it
about records that you love so much
why records ah it's a good question
except of the really really crunchy rare
special
sounds that only records can provide
that's the easy
uh answer i can tell you that these days
this these generations they had
playlists
most of the day now when was the last
time
that you sat and gave an artist the
honor to listen to his
whole album you can't listen to pink
floyd in a
in a hit list okay it can't be before
ricky mountain and after maroon time
so i sit and i have this exactly 40
minutes
of something i love it i i
couldn't agree more and you know i may
i'm particularly a broadway fan and it's
impossible to take out a song and just
listen to it
you have to understand the story the
context and especially when you're
talking about artists like pink floyd
it's all about the context which
unfortunately is lacking in some
in some of today's listening habits but
we're not here to talk about music we're
actually here to talk about
pricing intelligence and robbie's
journey
and so tell me a little bit about how
you even get yourself
into the tech world and specifically
into this in this in this idea of demand
prediction and pricing intelligence
okay it's a good question
because i i did most of my career since
i was
22 in the advertising industry in israel
i started as a copywriter in tbwa tel
aviv
and i ended up by being the
chief creative officer of tbw tel aviv
and then i
moved and was one of the founders and
the chief strategy
and creative of havas tel aviv it was
called in bangladesh
and most of my life i was doing
i was very sensitive about people's
behavior
that's the essence of advertising to to
have your senses
all the time aroused and to to listen to
feel the things that people don't say
to try to expect and to predict
their behavior now i didn't know that
in the other world where machines
they're doing the same things in other
industries such algo trading in all
these uh
places and nasa but uh i grew up
by always trying to be one step forward
than the competition by understanding
what will be the next need the next
demand
now um
[Music]
one of the decision that i've made when
i left
the advertising world when i became
40 is that i'm going to dedicate
the next 40 years of my life or the
second 40 years of my life
to break each and every glass walls
that i put in front of myself in my
first 40 years
you know i love that when you're uh
when you're a creative person they
always tell you
you do the creative you don't understand
nothing about money you don't understand
nothing about business
you deal with the creative you're the
talent you know nothing about clients
you know nothing about this and all the
things that i told myself you don't know
how to you don't have talent to play
guitar
you don't have talent to learn another
language okay so you
all the time the society and yourself
are putting glass walls now it comes to
a point
when you reached all the peaks that you
wanted to achieve
that when you're asking yourself what
i'm going to do in the next 40 years
i'm going to take one big hammer and and
i'm going to slam
each and every one of them so i learned
to play electric guitar
i'm not a talent i'm not david gilmour
but um
i cannot even warm him but i'm i'm
really enjoying myself i'm look
i know four languages i even
bought a drill because my wife doesn't
let me even put a nail because she says
i have left hands
but it's not right i didn't use it but
i'm gonna build something i don't know
what but i
bought it already so one of the things
was i'm very technophobic
okay um i write on my hand
you see uh things that i need to do um
i don't count on technology because it
always failed me in the money time
in my biggest presentation always was
something in this
she was never my friend now um
i i lost technology when it
it came to the um internet uh
era but when it came to the mobile i
came back
because the mobile and apple
specifically were designed for stupid
people like me it's just pressing things
and okay i'm in my bank okay wow i can
do this
wow i can do this in one press so yes
now i'm very digital
but um
i never was interested in how
technology works i love the outcome of
technology and what it
what needs it serves to the human being
and uh um because he and
and i never was interested in that so
when
a friend my partner and our ceo and my
friend and my neighbor
roy cohen came to me and
told me about the idea of trying to
create some really high-end
digital technology stuff that
only he understood what he was telling
me i
i was the my first instinct was
what's for me that i i i'm what can i
contribute
okay i don't i'm scared of technology
you want you're talking to me with
with phrases i don't understand he's
coming from e-commerce for the past
15 years he understands pricing and
tactical pricing and all these equations
and
reversed auctions and all kinds of
really sophisticated phrases
and my first instinct was no no i i can
consult you when you're gonna
want to build a brand and you're gonna
have this and this is but no i'm not
gonna
come there and be one of the founders of
something like that
and the minute i said it right i
understood
that this is the glass wall i was always
waiting for
okay to build something like that
you know to deal with money with
investors
with fundraising me creative
and to deal with technology and with
high-end technology and with phrases
that i don't know
and to understand it in a level that i
can sit with michael mattheus
and b with enough confidence to talk
about technology
imagine what challenge it was for me
three three years ago
wow robbie i i get so i it's i love this
conversation i love this story
you know usually i you know most people
in your position
they grew up as programmers or as
finance people or business people and
they were
you know working their life building up
to this moment where they're gonna
you know talk about you know their
journey and here you are telling that
three years ago you were technophobe and
and and i just love that i i have to
you know delay for a second about this
idea of breaking glass ceilings
what why why is this such a you know a
big part of your life i think that you
can
only real
live you can only do it while you're
growing
if you're not growing you're not living
you're existing
now you can grow
to the sides but eventually you do the
huge steps
by growing by defeating your fears
because you're gonna get
to learn new uh aspects of your
personality that you never
discovered before and it gives you the
appetite to discover
more and more before you die because you
understand that you have so many to
reveal right and so
now that you're you know past this glass
ceiling and i have no doubt that there's
going to be more glass ceilings
that you're going to break along the way
what do you do
what what is it about both you know
fetcher
but also pricing intelligence that
really gets you excited
okay first of all uh in the army
i served in the intelligence because
it's also understanding
i don't know siri just pumped in siri
uh close
okay
with this remote podcast always
always i love that we're keeping this in
the editing
i love this okay is it going to be more
because she's not the living she's uh
there is this uh you know the siri thing
moving there
okay so um
intelligence is also trying to
understand what the other side thinking
what is uh
uh how can you manipulate him how you
can understand
the bigger picture how can you
understand between the lines
all the things that interest me since i
was young
now you know i heard
while i was technical technophobe i
heard this kind of things of
price discrimination you know they're
big things that were the news
of the algorithms that know who's you
are and
offers you different prices and this is
for me it was like hmm
it was like a spa of looking at deep
blue
okay you remember the machine okay it's
like
wow you're probably better than i
but i wanna test you to see how good am
i
and to see if why does uh
these machines replaced you know in the
old days
when there was a stock market and there
was a mr microsoft
if you want microsoft you go to this
person in 20 years he follows
he's the man he's 80 years old but uh
he's doing
so how come a machine knows better than
him
okay and um right
when rohit came to me i love
pretentious ideas i love them okay
if somebody comes to me and let's say
let's do a keyboard with a little screen
that tells you what you're typing it's
boring for me
okay i know that it might be very um
commercial success but i'm not
interested i like things
you know when you're gonna ask me at the
end i'm gonna spare you this question
uh uh people that inspires me
okay that
you know are the all the people
that are trying trying to live a little
scratch
on the globe before they leave a little
not everyone succeeded but in their own
place in their own little bubble
to scratch the world once before they
die
so um he came to me and he told me
we have two more founders we're four
founders it's a
roy cohen uh shimya vismil
he's a genius in uh implementing he was
the head of the financial department in
matrix
so he knows how to deal with uh very
old heavy uh structures and
dr aurier who showed me that he is the
brain
uh behind this dream i'm i
i only know how to talk nice and to make
michael matthew smile
but eventually to do this thing you need
the real brain
so um doctor who shot me when
uh let us meet together i was fascinated
because like myself he was born in iran
and um he's a computer wizard because he
has his first uh
phd in neural science in 2006
one of the first in israel in the past
15 years he's been the head
of the leading companies in manhattan
that does
alga trading with the models that
all their job is to understand the
uh market dynamics and demand prediction
and continuous pricing
it's war levels in the in the star wars
technology okay so um
and he's very humble and very
and all of us are above 45 okay
we're old farts and uh um
we we're there and you know we live in
the same neighborhood our children
are studying the same classes we know
each other for so many years each one of
us did a totally different career
and we came up together and we said what
if
like robin hoods you know
there are markets that are very
sophisticated like algo trading
e-commerce that all the
decision-making of pricing and demand
prediction
and competitor behavior are done by
algorithms
okay but they're huge traditional
markets like
aviation banking hospitality car rentals
cruises
insurance okay a cargo logistics
that still this decision are being taken
by humans
based not on real-time data report based
now it's amazing to see how huge
brands and and companies in the world
i'll give you an
example
a huge airline company
a six-star alliance okay that
does more than 25 million passengers a
year
uh the people that are responsible to
price
you have average between 15 to 20 people
in the department that needs to do more
than 100 000 flights
now of course they can't do it so they
take the the most wanted ones and they
put the price on the other and come to
check it after a month
and they can't it's like a float now in
the in the
alga trading if you go today you will
see
huge brains that neural brains that can
absorb
so many data points for so many things
whether capital markets news pandemic
whatever you want
stock markets and digest it correlates
it and try to
understand what the human brain cannot
do
okay and to try to understand from all
this mess
what will be the demand what will be the
behavior
so we we thought if we can be like robin
hoods and create
one model for all industries one model
one brain that can migrate easily
these markets and give them the
abilities of these markets
we will cut all the hubs
that grow in the way that are taking the
money of the
end consumers and the sources
and we can create a world that is much
more commoditized
much more advanced that the companies
will gain the best and the end consumer
will gain the best
so that was a huge challenge imagine how
many
enemies you're going to put on your head
while challenging
these industries by giving them it's
like pomateos giving the fire
okay so yes let's do it let's bring the
fire
and see what happens i i can't imagine
uh you know the the both the
exhilaration the excitement but the
challenges that come with this
and you know i feel like we're just
robbie we're just starting to scratch
the surface
with what you're doing but i have i do
have to say that you know i'm leaving
this conversation with
a unique inspiration you know about this
idea of breaking glass ceilings and
you know being flexible and open-minded
and i just love
i love the journey that you shared with
me so thank you very very much
and i have a few final questions you
already answered one of them
but i do have two more questions for you
and the first one is going to be
what is your favorite subject or one of
your favorite subjects
from middle school or high school i
generally prefer middle school those are
more fun
from middle school to high school till
today the bible
really what is it about the bible
imagine that the most intelligent people
in history throughout the ages found
this book
as very relevant to their life in any
aspect
in any right in any place in time
so when you read it and i took the
challenge and i read the whole 24 books
of the tanakh because i wanted to see
what's the big deal
and it's a big deal because once you
understand it you understand that all
the changes is instead of gallabia
i'm wearing a t-shirt and instead of a
camel i have a car
nothing changes the your yetzel
your passions your your uh your core
values
your lighthouse
i i recommend to each and every one of
us before they judge
religion and judaism read the bible
the whole 24 books wow i
it's a lot of books yeah i i definitely
enjoyed it my
my my time in those classes as well
and what are three words that you would
choose to describe yourself
if i would ask anybody who is robbie
who's robbie
i don't know but i want to tell you um
what i trying
to do in my life
i don't know if it was absorbed by the
society but
what i'm trying to do
always always always be sensitive
sensitive not by the by the first
meaning
but also meaning that all your senses
are all
time working senses
i'm trying to be very sensitive to
people but to nature
and to thoughts and to new ideas and to
everything it's hard
because it's easy to stay on one sense
but try to keep all of your senses uh
open
to be very curious and to keep walking
because i think that you can't really
change people but you can inspire
them so do your thing
and i agree keep walking
grow i love that
being sensitive keep working grow robbie
i really want to thank you for spending
the time with me
i i loved it thank you very very much
definitely the best setting i've seen
for an interview here
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
very much
here as well thank you very much for
your time michael
thank you take care